[Musique]
protéger chacun de vous au quotidien est
le sens de notre engagement
plusieurs ambiances et plusieurs
interventions policières en l'espace de
30 secondes seulement le tout valorisé
avec des images soignées la nouvelle
campagne de communication de la police
nationale se veut juste et efficace pour
tenter de convaincre les plus jeunes de
devenir policier toutes les facettes du
métier sont mises en avant il y à la
police judiciaire l'investigation la
police secours la police du quotidien
mais aussi des métiers de geek comme la
cybercriminalité motocyclistes de la
police crs en milieu montagnard c'est
vraiment le métier qui s'offrent aux
jeunes alors oui on a voulu montrer
cette diversité
mais le point commun entre tous ces
métiers c'est l'objectif ultime
préserver la paix publique protéger les
gens pour ce premier spot diffusé à la
télévision depuis 18 ans une vingtaine
d'agents joue les comédiens parmi eux
plusieurs yvelinois durant trois jours
de tournage ils ont ainsi pu découvrir
un nouvel univers
c'est une belle expérience quoi j'avais
jamais vu en tournage en vrai donc non
c'était ces tests est cool mais les deux
premiers jours je peux vous assurer que
je rentrais chez moi j'avais très froid
au début au début du tournage c'était
chiant c'était clairement science ce que
toutes les deux secondes ce qui est
trois secondes poupée tournée est coupée
tournée et c'est vrai qu'on n'est pas
habitué ces essais mais après quand on
voit le résultat final sera qu on est on
est on est vraiment content pendant
cette fête en plus de la télévision
différents clips sont également diffusés
sur les réseaux sociaux selon un sondage
réalisé pour cette campagne près de 31 %
des jeunes ont déjà pensé à entrer dans
la police 8000 postes sont à pourvoir
cette année